all right so now we have another one
with the massage tool this is wonderful
for the back now I do this lying down
but you can do it sitting up so you want
to take the medium width alright because
we're going to be pressing this on her
spine and what we want to do is take the
long one
not the shorter one the long one down
with the smallest one on the top so
we're going to put this right here and
we're just going to have a lean back
okay and the whole pressure there ok so
just gonna hold apply some pressure and
maybe about 30 seconds and then she's
going to just let it lift up a little
bit now the question is how you gonna do
this to yourself okay so what I do is I
basically take it and push it on my back
so if you can just take that with your
hand you can try to position push it in
your back I mean like just set it back
there see if you can do it yeah perfect
let me just help so what you have to do
is you have to kind of play with it it's
good if you have someone else to help
you but so we're going to lower this a
little bit right here okay and she's
gonna hold that for 30 seconds and we're
gonna go right down the spine we're
getting each segment now there are two
sets of muscles that run along the spine
and we want to just come down here and
just work each one of them out couple
minutes and then we're gonna come down
this way okay now when we because the
chair dips we have to turn this around
try that now Roxanna is that better yeah
so we just have to adjust it depending
on the angle of the back of the chair so
she has her own little massage tool
using her gravity and we can go right
down the spine right here and get every
segment okay now I'm going to turn this
around
no actually I'm not it works better just
like right there so now you could
probably lean back a little bit and put
pret yeah right there and really get
that stress out of there if you do this
before you go to bed it's not only gonna
make your neck looser it's going to pull
a lot of stress out of your upper back
okay come up and then we're going to
bring this up right here okay so so
that's how you would do a sitting
maneuver with the massage tool to pull
the stress out of the back